so in the summer of 2020 after 10 years
of excruciating pain i finally got my
architecture license but that same year
i decided to take a job at an interior
design firm you want to know why watch
the rest of this video
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dani and i'm
a licensed architect in beautiful
vancouver bc
on this channel we talk about
architecture and design and also some
tools and strategies that can help us
have more meaningful and fulfilling
careers in architecture so in this video
i'm going to talk about the difference
between interior design and architecture
from the type of projects to liability
and licensure
the design process
education career
and as i go through this you'll probably
kind of get a sense of what type of
skills and personality type would be an
ideal fit for each but i'll also give
you my personal thoughts on this
so in a very general sense
architects design buildings including
the envelope the foundation the roofs
and interior designers they design the
spaces within that shell and this
difference in scale actually has a huge
impact on the work itself and your
day-to-day i would say the biggest
difference is actually the speed the
timeline for an interiors project is
much much much shorter than an
architecture project like within the
time span of a few months or like just a
few years you go from concept to
construction to completing a project in
an architecture project the process of
going from concept to construction
it could take years
and a lot of times you might decide
after doing a feasibility study that you
know the project is not even worth
continuing so if you are someone who's
in this design field to
see the thing that you designed get
built which is you know totally valid
interior should definitely be a
consideration for you but as an
architect you can also work on interior
fit outs or renovations which is where
it gets a little bit confusing but this
is actually very very common i did
interior fit outs for a big part of my
career and those are actually the only
projects that i saw from start to finish
i would say that the biggest distinction
it actually really comes down to the
liability and the licensure and the
ability to stamp and seal drawings and
pull permits so in most north american
jurisdictions even if you're doing very
minor work you still need to apply for a
permit
and when your interiors project involves
things that could compromise the health
and safety of the occupants of a
building you need someone who can sign
and seal the drawings and take liability
for their work aka someone who can get
sued if something goes wrong and that
person
in most cases is a registered
professional like an architect or an
engineer so
it's very common for interior designers
to
work with either of these people either
as a consultant or as a in-house
architect but there are some
jurisdictions like alberta that also
allow registered interior designers to
sign off on code related items and pull
permits for minor interior retrofits
personally i think interior designers
should be able to sign off on these
interior renovations
because building code is a very big part
of their education
and the process of becoming a registered
interior designer teaches you things on
like life safety and health of the
occupants but i think because interior
design is a relatively new profession
compared to architecture or engineering
most jurisdictions don't allow them to
sign and seal the drawings yet
the design process is actually where it
gets really interesting so in my opinion
the biggest difference between an
architect and an interior designer is
that architects work in the realm of
function
and interior designers work in the realm
of new
[Music]
obviously there is overlap but i'd say
that's the biggest distinction that
impacts the design process so when an
architect starts the design process we
meet with the client and we talk about
the site the landscape
and we talk about all the code and
zoning requirements like how much can
you build how high can you build and
we'll talk about the functional and
physical constraints to understand you
know if the project is feasible because
there's so much money involved and once
we have a good understanding of those
parameters we start diagramming
programming and massing and before we
even get into the design or like the
look of the building we'll have at least
a couple of meetings where we're just
talking about the massing and how it
works with the site and the feasibility
of the project and once we have a
direction
then we actually start the actual design
of the building when interior designers
start the design process
it's very much connected to the feeling
and the mood of the space
as well as the functional parameters by
the way i've only worked at one interior
design firm so if you are an interior
designer and you have other ways of
operating please let me know drop it
down in the comments so that we can all
learn so at my firm we would meet with
the client and we would talk about their
ideas for the space like what kind of
impression or
like mood they want to create and if
they have any inspirational images they
bring that and we
gather all of the descriptive words
or imagery or any kind of branding
guidelines from the client
and from that we create a mood board the
mood board is not made up of building
elements but any images that illustrate
the feeling that you're trying to
capture in the space at my firm we had a
grid of images and text on the side that
we could present to the client and the
text would work with the images to
create a
poetic description of the mood that
we're trying to create when i first
started at the sperm it was actually
really hard for me to wrap my head
around this like new approach
but um
oh man like clients loved it
like
i'd never seen that kind of involvement
from a client before and it was a really
really cool process but you have to be
really good at describing this mood and
also in building rapport with the client
because you are selling something that's
a lot more elusive
and i learned so much during my time
there and i feel like architects could
learn so much from working with interior
designers
so both architects and interior
designers have to get through the formal
education process professional work
experience under a supervisor and after
that we have the exam i actually have a
video on the step-by-step process of
becoming an architect i'll leave it
right here so i just did a quick search
in the cidq
website and it seems like there's a
similar amount of requirements in terms
of work experience hours in interior
design it's
3520 hours and in architecture it's
3750 hours the biggest difference
between architecture and interior design
is at the cidq which is like the council
for interior design qualifications in
north america
they allow you to count up to
1760 hours before you graduate so this
actually makes a pretty big difference
because a lot of people work between
school over the summers
and
if you use those hours you can take off
like almost half of your work experience
i'm not entirely sure what the interior
design exam is like all i know is that
it's a three-part exam but
if you have any experience with this
please let me know
so i did spend some time thinking about
how i want to cover the section because
obviously there's a million different
routes you could take in your career
depending on what you're interested in
you could work for a firm and you can
move up in that firm
or you could specialize in one aspect of
the job
or you could go and start your own
practice and because there's so many
things i could talk about i'm just gonna
try to focus on the aspects that i was
personally interested in in terms of my
career ambitions and professional growth
so
for me
there's one principle that's kind of
guided my career and i've spent a lot of
my energy on trying to achieve this and
it's kind of formed the basis for
deciding which skills i want to focus on
and it's this idea of the linchpin i
first learned about this idea from seth
godin and a linchpin is basically a
person who is indispensable it's someone
who is vital to an organization i think
about this a lot not because i'm like
hyper competitive or anything like that
but because i think being a linchpin
means
you can have more freedom and you start
to have options in where to work and how
to work and
being indispensable means that your time
is worth more to that organization so
when your time is worth more you can
either increase your salary or you can
reduce your hours of course every
organization has their unique needs
but
after working for a few firms and just
like trying to pay attention to how the
business side of it works
i
eventually realized that the fastest way
to make yourself indispensable
and valuable is if you can attract work
or money or clients so how do you do
that so first of all obviously you have
to have the foundational skills to be an
architect but on top of that it's great
if you have a unique skill
like marketing or branding or
videography or it could be with
connections like if you can actually
bring in interesting work
that's probably the top tier of moving
up fast in a firm or it can be with a
qualification for example if you are
lead or passive house or rick hansen
certified the firm could put you down on
a project that requires those
certifications ideally it's a skill or
qualification that the firm can charge
more money for and unfortunately in most
cases the firm's not going to be able to
charge more money for having these uh
certifications but like having more
qualified people will help the firm win
more work what they can definitely
charge more for
is like the difference between a
registered architect and an intern is
pretty big for example and the
difference between being a registered
architect in an architecture firm
and a non-architecture firm is also
pretty big let me explain
so for example if you're a licensed
architect and work for an interior
design firm which is what i did
you can advise on things like zoning
regulations like building code and you
can stamp the drawings right so
typically an interior design firm will
get an architecture consultant
and pay them to stamp the drawings so by
having your license you're saving them
thousands of dollars and you can tell
your clients that we have a registered
architect on the team
who can oversee all that
and that brings a level of credibility
and trust if you can bring this on top
of having the basic skills to function
in this role you will become very
valuable and you will be able to move up
very quickly in that firm and you will
be able to make more money in this case
your role as an architect is much more
valuable than being an architect in an
architecture firm with 10 other
architects who have the exact same skill
sets and qualifications as you
especially if you go just outside of
architecture let's say you work for a
developer or for the city lots of
development firms or city positions they
only hire licensed architects in this
case it's not because they can stamp
drawings but because they have the full
range of experience required to run a
project so i think there is a lot of
different ways you can provide a unique
value proposition to areas just outside
of an architecture firm with your
architectural license but of course the
most effective way of becoming a
linchpin
is of course starting your own firm i'm
actually curious how many of you are
thinking of going this path i'm actually
thinking of interviewing some people who
have done this so let me know in the
comments if you're interested in this i
think having the goal of running your
own business is awesome and inspiring
you have autonomy
you don't have a cap on how much money
you can make
but
it's risky
and it's a lot of work and it's just not
for everyone but if that is what you
want to do and you want to do that
fairly early on
i think the barrier to entry is somewhat
lower in interior design compared to
architecture like when you look around
you'll see a lot more
younger entrepreneurial interior
designers starting their own firms than
young architects first reason i think is
because while interior projects are
faster you're gonna be able to get more
experience and build up a portfolio
earlier in your career and second reason
i think it's the amount of time it takes
to become an expert
in interior design is shorter in
architecture i think the growth is much
slower because buildings
they are really complex and
i think because your career growth is
kind of parallel to how many projects
you work on and how many projects you
lead so by the nature of architecture
projects being bigger and taking a lot
longer
i think it just takes more time
it takes more years to be ready
to
run your own firm another thing is i
think a lot of architects don't get the
project management or entrepreneurial
experience when they're working at a
firm
but i got the sense that in interior
design firms you are the one who's
dealing with the client you are the one
whose project managing
and you have well at least the firm that
i was at we all had access to
the budget of each project so you knew
exactly how much time you had to spend
and you knew exactly how much money was
left on the project so i think the
business side is more of an integral
part of being an interior designer
compared to architects so i think that's
probably another reason why the learning
gap is a little bit shorter for interior
designers when they want to start their
own firms also there's the clients you
can get right because interior designers
are smaller and they're less expensive
and therefore they're less risky so you
will be able to get more clients
compared to architecture work for
example let's say a client wants a
six-story 26 million dollar building
they're gonna want someone they can
trust
someone with experience in that building
type
and for an architect to see these
projects through they will have to have
worked in the field for at least 10
years working on that same typology as
opposed to a client who wants to spend
one million dollars on an interiors
project
because they're relatively smaller and a
smaller amount of money it's less risky
and yeah like the client can hire
someone based on experience but i think
they'd be more willing to take a chance
on like new and up-and-coming designers
it's also easier to meet these types of
clients in your day-to-day
like when i was doing freelance work as
an intern i was connected to quite a few
clients for interiors work and you know
i did work for them even though i didn't
have that much experience i think this
also means that you have to be more of a
people person in interior design but
i'll talk about that later just to wrap
up this section i think at a certain
point in your career
you will have to make the choice of
whether to stay in your firm or start
your own business
and
for some people like you'll get to a
point where it makes more sense for you
to start your own business i personally
i'm very interested in starting my own
business but i just want to make sure
that i have all the necessary experience
before taking the leap
so in interior design you're selling a
mood which i think is harder than
selling something with rational hard
constraints behind it like the building
code or zoning regulations like when
you're an architect you can very easily
tell the client okay like this is what
the code says and so you know this are
the limits of what we can work with but
in interior design you're really working
in the realm of like feelings and moods
and atmosphere
so as an interior designer i think you
have to be a great communicator you have
to be great at selling your ideas you
have to be more personable you have to
be amazing at dealing with clients and
managing relationships not just with
clients but like everyone you work with
like i remember when i was at the
interiors firm like we would go for
beers with clients and like product reps
and whenever they came in they like
actually liked coming to our office
and like they knew all of us by name
and that rarely happened
in the architecture firms that i work
for also because there's less risk and
liability i think it makes more sense
for interior designers to go out on
their own and so if that's the case you
know having an entrepreneurial mindset
and you know being able to inspire
others that's an important skill but
even if you're working for a firm
most of the times you are going to be
managing your own project and handling
your own clients
so i think these skills are
really important if you are an interior
designer in architecture i think there's
a wider variety of roles you can play
which will also determine the skills you
need but in general if you want to start
your own firm or move up into a senior
position
i think you need to have all the skills
that i just mentioned like selling your
ideas like relationship building and
just like being a likable person
um this might sound kind of strange but
you'd be amazed at how many people
um architects who are just not a people
person and i think that's totally fine
but to be totally frank i think you will
have a hard time opening your firm
if that is what you're interested in i
think being in any senior position in
architecture you need to be good at
working with people and you need to be a
good conductor of people with different
skill sets but you know moving up into a
senior or managerial position isn't the
only way to have a successful career in
architecture like if you specialize and
become really good at one thing in a
large firm
you can also make pretty good money
but you know whichever direction you
choose every architect has to start at
the bottom
as an intern architect or a junior
architect and in general i think one of
the most important skills for an
architect is the ability to
digest lots of complex
often technical information
and communicate it in a simple way
by using both graphic and verbal
communication all right so i hope that
was helpful in understanding the
difference between architecture and
interior design i think there is a lot
more i could go into especially in the
career and skills sections
but i'm also trying to navigate this
profession myself so
my summary is actually really based on
my personal experience and my personal
interest something i kind of want to
mention is i i talked about the linchpin
principle but i you know i've tried to
follow the framework throughout my
career but i've also made a lot of
decisions that don't perfectly align
with that philosophy for example when i
got the position as an architect at the
interior design firm it was fantastic
like i was ecstatic and i was set up to
move up in that firm
but to my surprise
and to everyone's surprise i realized
after a while that you know i wasn't
really ready to niche down
and i just wanted to try working on
different types of projects and focus
more on learning new things i think this
linchpin mentality is something you
should always have no matter what firm
or what field you're in but you need to
balance it with your interests and your
passions once you find something that
you really like then you can put all
your heart and soul into it
but you know it's okay to take more time
in the exploration and learning phase as
long as you're constantly growing design
is a really fun profession
and in a lot of ways it's a forever
profession
which means that you never really stop
learning but
it is very easy to burn out or get jaded
if you don't put yourself in a position
to get properly rewarded for your work
which is why i try to urge people to get
licensed early and you know whether
you're in an architecture firm or an
interior design firm pay attention to
what brings value to that firm and also
try to constantly be thinking about what
you enjoy doing and what you want to get
better at
and how you can contribute to the field
in your own unique way i think if you do
that no matter which path you decide to
go into you will do well anyways if you
have any questions or things you want to
add feel free to drop it down in the
comments if you're interested in
learning how i got my architecture
license in less than four years i'll
leave the video right here if you're
interested in learning more about the
value of becoming licensed i'll also
leave the video right here
and if you're not interested at all in
this technical information and just want
to watch some videos on architectural
concepts i have a video on one of my
projects and i'll leave it right here
all right thanks for watching guys
as always i'll see you in the next video
bye
[Music]